heavily fortified this once bucolic
Community is the next Target of Putin's
War Machine
thousands of Russian soldiers are
heading this way
a maneuver the Kremlin hopes will cut
off the dombas and the Russian front
line is just over the brow
of that hill and there is very heavy
fighting there at the moment
as we drive we pass smashed up houses
only a few people remain
in the Central Square Michela who tells
us he's not scared takes us to where the
last bombs landed
there's another massive crater in the
road here
another Stripe from a rocket
and over here
this building it's the library
and it's still burning
everything here has been destroyed the
books turned to Cinders and Ash
ES
We Carry On up the road reaching a
freshly dug defensive position
soldiers repair tanks they'll need in
the coming fights
the front looks and feels like a war
from another Century a conflict the
world thought it would never see again
on European soil
um
across these positions there are now
hundreds of meters of trenches
a Labyrinth of protection where the Army
has laid down nests of weapons
the ukrainians are extremely well dug in
to their positions in many places
rights going up behind you now
and as we film Rockets streak over heads
it is a deadly fight where long-range
artillery will be decisive
in this maze there are many deep bunkers
sanctuaries from the incoming fire
many of the men have been living here
like this for months
yevgen shows us the german-made
anti-tank weapons he'll be firing
but as I am
resilience
Western Arms are flooding into this war
and it's why the Kremlin claims it's now
in a proxy fight with NATO and the West
foreign
so many of these towns and Villages have
been devastated by the fighting this was
once a school
but in this Russian invasion now a slow
slugging match of attrition and
Firepower
nothing is sacred
Alex Rossi Sky News eastern Ukraine